ces images publiées par le Hamas
montrent deux missiles israéliens
intercepté par les Palestiniens avant
qu'ils n'atteignent Gaza
c'est ici de s'intensifier depuis que
des militaires israéliens
si Jordanie il y a deux semaines le
lendemain un palestinier a battait 7
juifs à l'extérieur d'une synagogue à
Jérusalem depuis les violences font des
victimes chaque jour
42 Palestiniens ont été tués depuis le
début de l'année un colon attiré sur le
fils de cette femme qui avait trois
jeunes enfants
mis à Jérusalem où il couvrait le
conflit israélo-palestinien
c'est que avec l'extrême droite au
pouvoir en Israël c'est que des colons
se sentent légitimés à eux-mêmes
décrété de nouvelles colonies
à eux-mêmes s'en prendre
à des Palestiniens
la meilleure réponse à la terreur dit-il
c'est de l'attaquer et d'en créer nos
racines plus profondément dans notre
pays il annonce donc israël va légaliser
9 colonies en 6 Jordanie un territoire
palestinien et accélérer la construction
de nouvelles demeures avec l'histoire
des colonies ça fait des grandes villes
Palestine qui ont de plus en plus
encerclé toutefois par des colonies tout
autour
de béton qui vont les séparer par ces
colonies sont toujours protégées par par
des enceintes ça veut dire plus de
présence militaires pour protéger
équivalent qui sont sur place il y a 30
ans les Israéliens avaient reconnu le
droit des Palestiniens de vivre sur ces
territoires qui avait été largement
gruger
67 par l'installation de colonies juives
mais ils ont continué d'encourager
l'expansion de ces colonies le nombre de
colons israéliens vivant illégalement
dans les territoires palestiniens il est
ainsi passé de 100 000 en 1992 après de
800 000 aujourd'hui et c'est en
violation du droit international selon
l'ONU et la très grande majorité des
pays
la démolition de maison de Palestiniens
à Jérusalem Est provoque aussi la colère
visite du ministre extrémiste
à l'esplanade des mosquées
au lieu saint de l'islam une inquiétude
partagée par tous les musulmans ce qui
fait craindre que les tensions actuelles
n'explosent en conflit régional ici
Sophie Langlois Radio-Canada Montréal